[Musique]
Justin Trudeau est de nouveau hanté par
ses vacances les parties d'opposition
dénoncent son séjour au luxueux domaine
de réchami de la famille en Jamaïque un
voyage qui avait reçu le feu vert du
commissaire à l'éthique qui a répliqué
le Premier ministre mais à quel point la
vie du commissaire permet à un
politicien de calmer les critiques j'en
ai discuté avec l'ex-commissaire au
confinement
bonjour merci d'être avec nous bonjour
dans le dossier de Monsieur Trudeau la
semaine dernière mais on vous inviter
pour comprendre un peu ce qui s'était
passé comment ça fonctionne des
vérifications avant le voyage etc etc
merci d'être avec nous bon commençons
par la loi la loi sur la loi que vous
avez
gérer comme commissaire qui est
assujetti par cette loi-là
ça régit trois trois groupes trois gros
gros le premier c'est les ministres les
secrétaires d'État les membres du
personnel politique les gens dans un
cabinet du ministre et troisièmement les
gens qui sont nommés par le décret
quelques milliers de personnes à peu
près 3000 est-ce que les règles sont les
mêmes pour tout le monde que vous soyez
un ministre que vous soyez un membre
d'un nommé par un décret quelconque un
conseil quelconque les règles ont
identiques que vous soyez ce membre du
tribunal du travail social par exemple
ou que vous soyez chauffeur du ministre
de l'agriculture ou de la ministre
d'agriculture ou que vous soyez le
premier ministre ce sont les mêmes
règles non on a beaucoup parlé sans
beaucoup des dernières années de votre
travail
qu'est-ce que cette loi là tant de
prévenir essentiellement
prévenir des situations qui sont soit
latentes ou qui pourraient surgir
soudainement où on a un conflit entre le
devoir les fonctions qui existent une
personne en attaque ministre par exemple
ou en tant que chef de cabinet d'un
bureau de ministre et ses intérêts
personnels et si les intérêts
pécuniaires
romantiques vraiment artistique faire
l'argent avec quelque chose c'est cela
la possibilité qui surgissent un conflit
qui a conflit qui vous place dans un
soyez tiraillé à d'autres mots entre vos
responsabilités au plan public et votre
intérêt personnel le Premier ministre la
raison pour laquelle on en parle
évidemment c'est que c'est le premier
ministre qui était sur la sellette la
semaine dernière ces vacances en
Jamaïque monsieur Trudeau a dit que
qu'il avait obtenu le feu vert
l'approbation d'une série de mots du
commissariat à l'éthique avant de partir
comme d'habitude nous vérifions toujours
avec le bureau du commissaire pour voir
si on fonctionne à l'intérieur des
règles c'est ce que je l'ai entendu
l'intention première c'est quelqu'un qui
travaille pour lui
quoi que des fois ça voudrait peut-être
la peine que les gens viennent eux-mêmes
justement pour éviter des distorsions
pour éviter des faits qui manquent donc
on vient nous voir généralement vous
pouvez sûrement deviner qu'on vient pas
nous voir six mois à l'avance donc c'est
généralement ça se fait peu de temps
avant l'événement et on nous donne les
paramètres nous on exprime une opinion
par écrit une opinion simple courriel
avec un conseiller on a une dizaine de
conseillers qui travaillent au bureau
qui travaille encore
chaque chaque ministre sont conseillés
chaque chef de cabinet à son conseiller
attisés dans le cas des ministres des
hauts fonctionnaires etc je voulais être
impliqué dans chaque cas
le conseiller dit ça ne viole aucune
disposition de la loi à notre avis vous
pouvez procéder le commissaire vu ça est
d'accord ça le conseiller envoie son
email au bureau du premier ministre il
dit à notre avis vous pouvez procéder
avec votre votre plaque parce que aucune
contravention on ne voit pas de
contrevention à la loi sur le confiture
de police d'assurance dans le fond c'est
ça c'est on vient chercher c'est
préférable de découvrir avant plutôt
qu'après c'est comme demander à ses
parents la permission
c'est mieux de le demander le vendredi
après-midi que le samedi soir
très légal voici la Loi sur les conflits
d'intérêts voici la situation que vous
vous présentez ça me semble être correct
puis il y a toute la question de la
perception publique vous avez twitté la
semaine dernière acceptable légalement
ne veut pas nécessairement dire que cela
sera au niveau de l'opinion publique
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire donc il y
a des situations où j'ai souligné aux
gens qui sollicitaient notre vie vous
pouvez accepter telle chose
cependant à mon avis vous vous courez un
risque étant donné la nature du cadeau
étant donné
l'identité du donateur vous vous exposez
à des critiques mais c'est pas mon rôle
évidemment de vous dire si vous pouvez
ou pas l'accepter parce qu'au plan légal
vous pouvez si on vient vous voir puis
qu'on vous demande une opinion puis que
vous émettez une opinion qui dit c'est
correct ça me semble être légal il y a
pas lieu de tenir une enquête ensuite
vous le commissaire est cohérent dans ce
qu'il fait on peut pas dire à une
personne ça va tu peux faire certaines
choses sur le bord un mois après puis
lancer une enquête si l'effet était
connu en fait si on nous a caché quelque
chose un élément essentiel
là ça change
du parti parce que
un jeune vole dans un parité puis oublie
de pensionné que les parents sont pas là
par exemple il va 2000 personnes des
choses comme ça c'est important parce
que tous les paramètres quand on demande
un avis soit on pose des questions
additionnelles parce qu'il y a des gens
par omission c'est quand on veut faire
quelque chose évidemment on n'a pas
intérêt à mettre toutes les paramètres
sur la table pour qu'on nous dise non
quand on parle inconsciemment même des
fois on nous met de mentionner le détail
on emmène parce que souvent on pose des
questions additionnelles justement qui
sont pertinentes à la question du
conflit d'intérêt ça change la lecture
est-ce que la personne a reçu des
subventions au cours des cinq dernières
années par exemple du gouvernement
est-ce que la personne est susceptible
est-ce que vous êtes susceptible de
participer à une décision impliquant à
la personne à l'avenir puis nous on
essaie de au mieux notre connaissance
d'évaluer la possibilité lorsqu'on est
premier ministre on est responsable de
tout donc le potentiel est beaucoup plus
grand que si on est ministre dans un
secteur restreint on a beaucoup joué sur
la notion d'amitié la semaine dernière à
quel point ça joue dans la balle parce
que la loi exclue en fait les cadeaux à
faire par un ami sont exclus de la loi
c'est parfaitement acceptable d'accepter
un cadeau venant d'un ami en notant que
l'ami justement ne participe pas à des
processus gouvernementaux comme des
subventions recevoir des subventions
qu'est-ce que comment la loi définit un
ami parce que si moi je suis lu demain
disons qu'on est amis depuis ça fait 15
ans qu'on se connaît on prend des
vacances ensemble on va au restaurant
souvent etc je suis élu la relation
d'amitié continue d'exister on peut
continuer à aller manger un cadeau à
Noël la loi prévoit ça à cause de ça
justement la loi de brise pas les
relations préexistantes les cadeaux qui
sont normaux entre amis
et quand on est amis quand on est
millionnaire on a des amis qui ont des
cadeaux plus gros que lorsqu'on
lorsqu'on est ouvrit c'est c'est facile
à comprendre la loi n'a pas de limite
quand à la valeur un cadeau provenant
d'un ami est en soi acceptable mais faut
que ce soit un vrai pas les amis de
Facebook donc il s'agit ok ça marche
ça peut compter mais il faut que ça soit
plus durable donc juste un jour j'ai
posé sur le Python pour devenir votre
merci infiniment bonne continuité de
retraite merci beaucoup